in November 2018 president Donald Trump
will face his biggest political test yet
you are hereby are the midterm elections
if Democrats do particularly well then
President Trump could be facing
impeachment proceedings the elections
are a referendum on the president his
achievements his ability to govern and
the scandals engulfing him there's a lot
of turbulence a lot of stuff going on
that is unsettling to people Donald
Trump is possibly the most controversial
American president of all time his
antagonized world leaders
Rocketman and stoked racial tension at
home was George Washington a slave owner
and abroad mr. Trump has redefined the
term public office what would have once
been private White House discourse is
now regularly broadcast to the world via
his Twitter account the first year of
Trump's presidency has been completely
extraordinary things that we haven't
seen from an American president really
ever despite Republican control of
Congress he's failed to deliver on his
promises he's had a kind of huge effect
on American politics the culture of
American politics in terms of actual
legislation it's all been pretty minor
with the exception of tax reform it mr.
Trump needs the support of his own party
to push through his agenda but the last
year has seen the president go after
senior Republican members John Kasich
Republican governor of Ohio has seen the
effect of mr. Trump's radical approach
much lies at stake for his party in the
2018 midterms people are generally not
happy with the negative tone that we see
the Republican Party split against each
other it's a very turbulent time
in the 2018 midterm elections it's very
possible the Republicans will be able to
hold what they have and keep their
majority in the House of Representatives
and in the Senate in the house the
numbers are stacked in the Republicans
favor having secured a strong majority
in 2016 in 2018 every member of the
house is up for election the Democrats
need to hold on to all their seats as
well as gaining an extra 24 to regain
control in the Senate the electoral map
is also stacked in the Republicans favor
Republicans are defending a lot of rural
states where they're still incredibly
popular if the Republicans hold or even
increase their majority it will define
the rest of mr. Trump's presidential
term it would not only give President
Trump more time to get legislation
passed and to reshape the country it
will also be a strong indicator that he
would be on track for re-election in in
2020 do you swear that the testimony you
are about to give shall be the truth the
whole truth and nothing but the truth
the Trump campaigns alleged dealings
with Russia are being investigated and
in 2018 the world will await the outcome
of the inquiry the investigation will
probably have concluded by the time the
midterms come around emboldened Trump
with a majority in both houses you know
might be tempted to squash its findings
history however is against him one
pattern has held true since the Civil
War
92% of midterms have seen the
president's party lose seats it will be
a comment on as it is in every off year
election how the kinky executive is
doing how they're doing in their lives
come November mr. Trump will need to
rally public favor
traditionally presidents with approval
ratings of 50% and below do badly in the
midterms with mr. Trump's ratings
reaching as low as 34% the likelihood
for significant Republican losses next
year is strong dissatisfied voters could
turn the house and the Senate blue this
would severely limit the president's
ability to pass legislation and affect
his change a Democrat majority could
even spark an attempt to bring down the
president if Democrats do particularly
well and get majorities in both the
House and the Senate then he could
potentially be facing impeachment
proceedings in 2019 but this is unlikely
2/3 of the Senate must vote for
impeachment and past attempts to impeach
presidents have misfired
a wounded President Trump could see in
ever more volatile administration if
Republicans did poorly in 2018 you will
see president who acts in a way that's
kind of even more unhinged than as being
the case already which is potentially
pretty alarming the most likely outcome
is that the Republicans will lose the
house and just about cling to a senate
majority this will cause political
stalemate in 2018 will be a pretty
unhappy year in American politics you'll
see legislative gridlock for American
voters who already pretty frustrated
with the way Washington works that makes
that frustration even worse 2018 may
well be Donald Trump's last chance to
make America great again
[Music]
you